hey what's going on it's bill burr and
it's time for the Thursday afternoon
just before Friday Monday morning
podcasted I'm just checking it on you
I'm just checking it on you to see how
your work weeks going you know [ __ ]
weird one this year fourth of July on a
Wednesday you know if it's on the
Tuesday maybe your boss gives you the
Monday off right you got a three-day
[ __ ] week after a four-day weekend
it's beautiful you know if it's on
Thursday maybe you don't have to come in
Friday there's afford a [ __ ] weekend
but not this year
oh no oh [ __ ] powdered wig itself
came in on a Wednesday [ __ ] everybody
Monday Tuesday right everybody [ __ ] off
for Wednesday now you gotta come back
Thursday Friday it's cool to get the day
off but you didn't get the consecutive
days off you know do you know you got
[ __ ] up the night of July 3rd right
and yesterday what you do you ate a
bunch of [ __ ] burgers is that what
you did I am finally on the other side
of this goddamn cold I I caught one of
these post global warming mother nature
is going to start getting rid of us
Colts this [ __ ] thing it came on slow
you know and then it just started
picking up speed and it just grabbed me
by the [ __ ] throat and just chokeslam
me yeah so I'm finally finally on the
other side of it no he wouldn't know
what to hear me right now but I have no
or thank all you guys for your postcards
and your well wishes meant a lot to me
you know when I was sitting laying there
in the hospital bed
I actually was the first guy who ever
went to the hospital for a common cold
in the San Fernando Valley area they
made a plaque for me and everything I
went in there and the doctor was just
like looking at my chart if I looked up
he's like so you got the sniffles and I
was like yeah he's like you know I have
a whole emergency room full of people
that got stabbed
shot and I was like yeah I know but like
one of my nostrils is like really
clogged up and I just can't like deal
man
that's a guys I saw that that
documentary on Mark Ronson Ted his name
no not Mark Ronson the [ __ ] guy who
played with David Bowie is Mark Ronson
the guy Mick Ronson Mick Ronson is the
one Mark Ronson is this is your mother
your father your sister whatever that
[ __ ] song is styling by and eating
some peanut butter
it's a [ __ ] summer dhaba do let me
see your titties all right this is not
on that song when Mick Ronson played
with David Bowie when he was Ziggy
Stardust and the spiders and [ __ ]
incredible guitarists credible musician
producer wrote songs you know learned
how to write out all the music and all
this [ __ ] he got no [ __ ] credit got
no [ __ ] credit didn't get any money
they [ __ ] them I just the music
business is the absolute worst I can't
tell you how many [ __ ] times I've
seen that you know the drummer and the
bass player on those first two aussie
solo albums like they just they just
[ __ ] those guys they just you know guys
coming in and writing riffs and writing
entire [ __ ] songs but they're - they
don't have a good lawyer nobody tells
them what's up
they don't get the guy you know and then
it's like song by Ozzy Osbourne and then
they they get [ __ ] out of millions of
dollars how do you do that to a kid it's
just this reoccurring thing in the
[ __ ] music business this [ __ ] guy
was writing all these riffs he was
writing the string arrangements he was
in the [ __ ] studio with one of those
conductor ones and they didn't even get
any [ __ ] credit it's [ __ ] brutal
but what was amazing was watching the
guy I saw him was like Jesus Christ that
kind of looks like [ __ ] Randy Rhoads
same aircard same [ __ ] Les Paul and
all that I'm like wait randy rhoads came
after Mick Ronson so then I just looked
googled Randy Rhoads Mick Ronson
influence and a bunch of [ __ ] came out
and saying that he was a fan is I
thought that was pretty cool you know
I'd already had more of the classical
guitar type of stuff in there but you
know say uh say yeah that's a good
documentary I saw it on a plane though
you know whatever you're on a plane tell
me everything's [ __ ] good guys a
little a DI [ __ ] I'm still I'm coming
out of this [ __ ] man you know I don't
know what it feels like to be trapped in
a mine you know I'll [ __ ] our there's
some kids right now trap somewhere the
news is just so brutal I just I want a
treat I just see like the headline I
just go oh I just walk away I don't know
how people just sit there watching other
people suffering it's one thing to say
hey these kids are trapped in a mine
right over there grab a shovel come with
me then you can do something but there's
just no this sitting there and there's
nothing you can [ __ ] do about it you
know kind of [ __ ] to a bunch of kids end
up in a mines I would have well the end
of mine I don't [ __ ] stuck on a giant
lily pad or something like that in the
middle of river I don't know I don't you
know I've been like [ __ ]
hallucinating all goddamn week but uh
one of the good things about being this
sick is I haven't drank in like [ __ ]
five days you know and I got some acting
work next week so whenever I got acting
work I shut down all the fun you know Oh
Billy no fun you know try to keep my
face not [ __ ] all [ __ ] puffy and
[ __ ]
so anyways oh god I got nothing Jesus
Christ I got nothing but I gotta lock
this up this is how funny I am when I'm
[ __ ] sick for five days I'm basically
not funny at all okay and I would
appreciate it if you guys would just cut
me a little bit of [ __ ] all right you
know what I had I had a few uh I [ __ ]
up when I was uploading the Monday
morning podcast when like am I the
battery on my laptop died
so 15 minutes in the middle got cut out
so we had to edit it edit it together so
there's some [ __ ] people wrote in
some questions I'm gonna re answer them
the best I can
by the way on Instagram I found this
account that I've been following called
don't be a brad and it's basically
trashing like essentially meathead white
guy frat boys you know it's funny they
kind of make kind of you know it's
hilarious because you know there's a lot
of truth to it but then also it's like
you're completely judging these people
by their skin color and nobody gives a
[ __ ] cuz it's [ __ ] white guys but a
lot of them are just really good-looking
guys who are in France and they're
getting a lot of [ __ ] and you're
[ __ ] annoyed by it because you're a
nerd so you started this account having
said that it is funny like they
literally have one of them yelling and
about to go do you know what my dad does
you know and everybody makes fun of
these frat kids it's not their [ __ ]
fault it's their parents it's like
making fun of Millennials it's like it's
not it's the people who raised them that
[ __ ] them up but it's a very funny
account albeit a lot of it you know it's
just uh Nath let ik people making fun of
people who are athletic and then there's
also something to well you know there's
a curse to being [ __ ] good-looking
you know I was reading this one time
this article in a Rolling Stone and this
guy who was just like this heartthrob
for [ __ ] 15 years it was now like in
his 60s and he was doing this [ __ ]
this interview and they were talking to
him and he was reflecting on what kind
of a person he was back in his 20s and
his 30s they said well you know I was
he's basically saying he was a really
good-looking guy he was on a TV show and
in movies and he had a big dick so he
only had to develop so much as a human
being was really fascinating so then
when he got old and he wasn't as
good-looking it was creepy to younger
women and [ __ ] he actually had
finished developing all the development
as a human that he never had to do
before cuz all he did was just show up
and all the women fainted he pulled out
his giant dick you know and he [ __ ]
went to tell he was done with Danny went
back to out of the movie cent and made
another hit movie was very very
interesting so I actually was thinking
of that when I was looking at that don't
be a brad Instagram account well it's
like this isn't these kids 100% their
fault like if your kid is walking around
acting like an [ __ ] and then going do
you know what my dad does for a living
you spoiled the [ __ ] out of that kid
that's your [ __ ] fault
dad I mean that's complete failure as a
dad if your kids out there being a
[ __ ] you know mouthing off to some
bouncer that could [ __ ] twist them up
like a pretzel and then screaming like
my dad's gonna come down here oh my god
I'd just be like son son fight your own
battles like what are you doing I want
to come down here we'll do what sue him
cuz you're a [ __ ] [ __ ]
I don't want to see you get a concussion
but he should have slapped the [ __ ] out
of you
alright Republican douche the question
mark hey Bill I'm a fan of your comedy
I'm still a fan of you but honestly
you're starting to sound like a red pill
Republican douche bag you know isn't it
just classically classic like way that
look like politics is discussed now you
know like his whole here the thing is
called Republican douche question mark
like I don't understand these people
where if if you're a Republican then
automatically you're a douche if you're
a Democrat you're automatically into you
know what I mean you know you don't say
like like you don't think anybody on
either like everybody on that side is
just douche bags anyways he goes no
offense they're always going on about
how Hillary is evil while our country is
going down the [ __ ] and she would
have saved us from a lot of these
headaches all right well that's pretty
vague our country's been going down the
[ __ ] for a long
I'm sir I don't know what you're talking
about what exactly wasn't it going down
the [ __ ] you know I was speaking of
that you know back in the of that
[ __ ] don't be a brad one of the frat
boys had Ronald Reagan tattooed on his
calf not a picture it just said Ronald
Reagan that [ __ ] was that's hilarious
to me you know Ronald Reagan is like
rich white people's Abraham Lincoln like
he set them free in a way by you know by
well you know deregulating everything so
then these [ __ ] robber barons could
get back to what the [ __ ] they wanted to
be doing oh look at that I just made fun
of a Republican sir do I sound like a
red pill Republican douchebag me this
guy is like literally speaking in sound
bites like how [ __ ] like how boring a
conversation would to discuss politics
with this person
anybody say you say you don't like Trump
Trump but you sound like a closet fan
who's just too afraid to say you love
him because you lose a part donut store
employee number two I think you missed a
word in there buddy I'm not afraid to
say that I like Trump if I like Trump I
don't like him I don't like him
and his [ __ ] wife the fact that she
wore that jackets that said I don't
really care do you when she was going to
see those kids and then tried to say
like oh that had to do with fake news
like there's such passive-aggressive
[ __ ] [ __ ]
there that had nothing to do with fake
news like you telling me nobody at the
White House this is about fake news well
just let you know there first lady
people might think you're talking about
the kids you might not want to wear that
it was such like a [ __ ] you know it's
bad enough for the guys that ignorant
but when a woman does it she's actually
had kids she knows what it's like to
have a [ __ ] kid and to sit there have
these kids and [ __ ] cages and she
wears a jacket like that's just an ass
[ __ ]
they're not human so anyways
he said I can't tell if it set your fan
baits is all a bunch of moderate morons
who would rather be contrarian 'he's
then pick the good guys or the bad guys
why don't you just pick a side cuz
clearly this is a good guy bad guy thing
going on here question mark that's
probably one of the most ignorant
condescending [ __ ] emails I've ever
gotten you didn't make one [ __ ] point
you just spoke in big broad soundbites I
get it I get it you're a Democrat and
you think everybody who's a Republican
is a douche and the country's going down
the [ __ ] and if we picked a Democrat
it wouldn't be going down the [ __ ]
and there are good guys and there are
bad guys and the good guys are Democrats
and the bad guys are Republicans right
hey by the way did you see the house the
Obama's just [ __ ] bought you know how
the [ __ ] did they have the money to buy
that [ __ ] house explain that to me
you know every [ __ ] one of them
whether you wear a blue tie or a red tie
they come out of the White House worth
[ __ ] you know tens of millions of
dollars other than Bill Clinton because
he stuck his cigar in that woman's [ __ ]
he had a lot of [ __ ] legal bills but
even they even the [ __ ] Clintons
ended up worth 300 civilians
well actually Bill Clinton said he came
out of the White House in debt but he
also said I did not have sex with that
woman so he probably had [ __ ]
millions of dollars I don't like any of
them sir I don't
I liked Bernie Sanders Bernie Sanders I
liked I'm not saying he would have
solved everything but uh
God knows he got me he got he got the
majority of the vote and the Democrats
said [ __ ] that we're still given the
dumb and the nomination to Hillary and
she was fine with that that had the
[ __ ] nerve to sit there and [ __ ]
about the [ __ ] election that last
election was 2:00 a.m. at a bar sir
there was no there was no winning
there was no winning that one I mean
Hillary literally said in 2008 to the
bankers don't worry I got you guys like
I'll basically cover for you guys I mean
you should be tried for [ __ ] treason
when you do [ __ ] like that I don't see
any difference between her or Trump I
don't they're complete pieces of [ __ ]
that are
for themselves who act like they're
there for you and it's weird if they
wear a certain colored [ __ ] shirt
half the country believes it all right
25 year old buying an old house all
right hey Billy dough boy I'm 25 years
old just graduated with my master's and
got a dream job a dream teaching job in
Philly you're teaching in Philadelphia
well you got your work cut out for you
I'm [ __ ] with you anyways I got my
dream job teaching in Philadelphia where
the [ __ ] did it just go I just lost
everything here Oh Billy all right okay
with how cheap the housing market is I
figured it would be a smart decision to
buy a house now rather than wait 10
years I found a great old house in
Philly it's in my price wage should be
price range
move-in ready and has all the details I
love about old houses they accepted my
offer and I closed at the end of the
month that's exciting 25 years old you
got a house dude you get your dream job
you're crushing it all you got to do is
pick the right lady and you're good you
picked the wrong one she'll take all of
it from you but you won't see that
hashtag on Twitter will you after
listening to your podcast for a couple
years I know that you have a love-hate
relationship with your old house yes I
do
is there any advice that you have for me
for me as I move in and make my first
real adult purchase thanks for keeping
me and many other teachers saying with
your podcast all right well if you're
gonna buy an old house of Jesus I don't
even know where to begin the first thing
I would start with is the guts of the
house if you got the money if you can
redo the electrical and the plumbing or
find out to what extent it has been
redone because I have a bunch of cloth
wiring and galvanized pipes in my walls
you don't want to fire and you don't
want to get flooded so that's usually a
big thing there um I also had a minor
gas leak you might want to look for
stuff like that once you get the guts
done then I would deal with the
cosmetics as far as you know there's
gonna be a bunch of [ __ ] you know I
check out your roof that's another thing
I would check for termites that's
another thing I actually have all like
the skeleton keys for every door in the
house then I got them so they all work
and then within two and a half three
years of doing it the house settled some
more and now most of the bolts don't
line up with the thing and I just stop
fighting the house after a while it's
just like all right I get it
this house is almost 100 years old and
it's gonna do what the [ __ ] it wants to
do so I would just you know once you get
the electrical the plumbing done that's
like the biggest thing then he can
slowly kind of fix up everything else
but and what I tried to do is you know
as I upgrade like you know you upgrade
the electrical and the plumbing nobody's
gonna see that so you know [ __ ] with the
character of the house but like the word
the worst thing you can do is is to take
stuff out of your house and replace it
with Home Depot [ __ ] I would find some
sort of old-school hardware store that
has just that those old doors from the
time of your house you can find those
places they'll have all the doorknobs
and all the locks and all of that [ __ ]
you can gradually just go room by room
and redo it you know what you're fine
with your old doors not only their odd
size they're also really heavy because
back then the trees they were cutting
down were much older than though it's
not wet wood or something that's more
dense wood I don't really understand it
but they're super heavy as opposed all
these [ __ ] wood and [ __ ] crap that
they have down at the Home Depot and the
worst thing what I like about your email
is that you actually seem to love old
houses because there's nothing worse
than someone who doesn't give a [ __ ]
about an old house buys it just to flip
it and it's funny as they got the house
to give it a makeover and everything the
guys that got it keep all the [ __ ] and
then they take it down in those hardware
stores and they sell it and then
[ __ ] like me you have to [ __ ] buy
it back to [ __ ] make the house look
right again
all right that's my advice my advice is
the plumbing the electrical in your roof
that's what I would start with then he
can deal with all the [ __ ] drafts and
all the other [ __ ] all right
I'm sorry guys my energy is just [ __ ] I
got nothing all right French guy with
muscular dystrophy looking for lady
advice Mon chere William Tet rush or is
that my something bill redhead I'm a 39
year old man you know I've taken a fancy
to this awesome lady
we sometimes spend time together working
on each other's professional and hobby
projects and we have lots of fun the
times we do hang out together to specify
we're not coworkers but we have a
similar circle of friends here's the
catch she's 27 but I'm 39 and have a
disease called muscular dystrophy in
case you don't know what it is it's a
disease similar to the kid in the
wheelchair in the Jim Jefferies show and
set the difference is that in my case
I'm a hard-headed guy refused to accept
my fate an exercise like crazy as a
young lad while I still had some muscle
mass to be able to physically function
well above expectations up to my adult
years that's great
it's only showed a little in the way
that I've walked but that's it also
being physically disabled has really
made me learn to not take anything for
granted and focus on my strengths which
is really increased my personality
skills and gave me game enough to have a
few great relationships not lower my
standards and it's worked so far all
right so what is the problem sir this
seems it seems all good
anyways since I've developed feelings
for this 27 year old girl I've been
hesitant to tell her about it if she
says no and rejects me no big deal I've
been rejected before like most other
guys out there and it's something I can
handle it's basically going to suck for
a couple days tops and everything is
fine after that but I guess I'm more
if she says yes she's still young I'm
hitting the gym as much as I can to keep
myself out of any wheelchair and
crutches and slow this thing down as
much as I can however in the past ten
years this disease has really been
taking a toll on me Jesus Christ I think
there's a [ __ ] that I [ __ ] about
there's someone dealing with this crap I
feel my body is going downhill to the
point that stairs now look like
mountains if I fall I can't get up on my
own which is scary to me this girl has
been single for a while and has been
complaining about being single but she's
also young and has her whole life ahead
of her and I'm not sure I'm if I'm still
going to be able to wipe be able to wipe
my own ass in ten years and I don't want
to put someone through the same pain in
the future as that woman and family guy
who's married to Joe in the wheelchair
should I confess my feelings and not
regret it you know so at least I tried
or should I just keep it to myself and
not waste a vital part of her life if
she does say yes merci beaucoup de leer
amen she should just sweet Frank whoa I
don't know what the [ __ ]
thanks a lot and same if I am something
I don't what is just C qua ma'am I mean
literally that's I am when same on gross
party okay I'm a big fan of the Bruins
and I hate the Montreal Canadiens with a
passion he wrote that in French as your
the Tesla Canadiens de Montreal avec une
Peschel just recalled man or girl dr.
Cynthia Bruins um I would [ __ ] tell
her everything you said to me so listen
I got feelings for you I really like you
but I'm 39 years old I have muscle
dystrophy you know and I don't know
waste you [ __ ] I wouldn't know if I'd
say all that I'd [ __ ] ask her out and
then you know if you guys hit it off
then I would say all that other [ __ ] you
know that makes sense just don't
the whole thing on earth don't talk
about never having to wipe your ass in
ten years so figure gotta be a [ __ ]
buzzkill but you know you do want to be
[ __ ] upfront I would I would think I
got a buddy of mine his wife's like that
she's got the same thing I thought she
is a mess I think so she has like days
what she's like super tired and
everything why do I complain about dumb
[ __ ] in life for those people like this
out there sir I would ask her out
okay she's a big girl she's [ __ ] 27
years old all right ask her out do every
you're probably [ __ ] living more in
the moment than most people you know
[ __ ] I mean life flies by forget about
when you're dealing with some [ __ ] that
you're dealing with so you know you're a
good guy you're actually care about you
know you should care about another
person like that you don't want to waste
the best part of their life
dealing with you but who knows maybe you
guys hit it off ask her out dude
ask her out you know but then it moves
on to another level then I would talk
about that other stuff and see what she
says
all right drug-dealing roommate this is
gonna be easy move out or kick him up
all right hey Billy ballbreaker up from
the I'm from right outside of Philly
another one don't hold it against me Dom
our air is a good [ __ ] I am nothing
against Philadelphia I just had a
[ __ ] tough show there okay and I made
fun of Philly if I was somewhere else or
what'm it's fun is somewhere else but I
don't have a problem all right but I'm
28 and one of my roommates is a deal oh
and congratulations filling what in the
Super Bowl you know I can say that now
the pains gone away it was great when I
first moved in at 22 and all I had to do
for some pot was walk upstairs but now
we've sort of grown up and he's pushing
some other [ __ ] which worries me about
the safety of our crib should I approach
him and ask him to knock it off or just
[ __ ] his girlfriend and end the
friendship that's hilarious
Thanks and instead of go [ __ ] yourself I
wish you the lovely Nia and your baby
girl nothing but the best see you and a
C in October go Birds go Birds is at the
Orioles is that the Eagles there's a lot
of birds down there
yeah what should you do well I don't
think when somebody's dealing coke
heroin what else would be up the ecstasy
meth I don't think you can just say hey
we you knock it off like they have their
stereo too loud I mean this person has
made a decision that this is how they're
gonna earn a living
so I would get the [ __ ] out of there is
what I would do I would not [ __ ] his
girlfriend because he might be trying
his own [ __ ] drugs and his drugs
might tell him to do some [ __ ] crazy
to you while you're sleeping so I would
I get the [ __ ] out of there is what I
would do because one of these days
you're gonna be asleep and the doors
gonna get kicked in it's gonna be the
cops and you're gonna be [ __ ] face
down with a boot in your back getting
[ __ ] handcuffed and then he they're
gonna be like did you know he's dealing
drugs no then he's gonna rat you up you
know that's [ __ ] he used to buy him
off me because he's a piece of [ __ ] well
maybe he's a good let me he's a drug
dealer with a heart of gold and he gets
you out of it yes you don't need that
the [ __ ] get out of there your name's on
the lease I would kick him out if he
doesn't leave then I would just find
someplace else to live all right let me
read a bit of advertising here oh look
who's back millions of people are using
hard to save money while shopping online
and why wouldn't they it's free takes
just two clicks to add to your browser
and save you a ton of saves you tons of
money it's ingenious but one of my
absolute favorite things about is how
much better it makes shopping on Amazon
please personalize this to make it your
own I am magically adds all sorts of
useful information right on the Amazon
page of whatever you're looking at just
shop like you normally do honey
automatically searches honey
automatically searches to two million
sellers on Amazon to find the lowest
price it even shows you item items
prices changes so you can decide if you
want to buy or wait for the price to
come down well they do this on Amazon
this is like what these little fishes
that swims next to the big fish the big
fish never eats it you know sort of
tolerates it if you do decide to wait
just add drop list and it will notify
you if the price drops when honey gets
you what honey's got your back you'll
never overpay for anything on Amazon
again there's no reason to add hottie to
your browser today not to add it to your
browser Tay it's free just takes two
clicks to install and we'll make sure
you always get the lowest price on
Amazon it's [ __ ] Free People add to
your browser for free right now at join
honeycomb slash trench that's join honey
dot-com
slash trends honey Wow all right you got
a couple more here borrow
you know people after a busy week is
there anything better than coming home
to your to a comfortable couch trouble
is your couch isn't that comfortable is
it maybe you fell for the Scandinavian
aesthetic you know what I actually did
we bought some fancy [ __ ] couch it
stinks there's too many pillows you just
can't even relax on it I hate that couch
maybe the cushions lost their pop for
old
ago whatever the case you owe it to
yourself to experience the comfort of a
borough couch made from murdered donkey
snow kitty burrow Springs style and
comfort to a new level and ships to your
door fast and for he your relationship
with your couch will never be the same
boroughs boroughs sofas are handcrafted
in the same factories in North Carolina
as other high-end retailers but borough
delivers them with for much less with
their innovative award-winning design if
it's been oregano mcclee designed to
allow for multi our Netflix binges
tripleheader game days and late night
work sessions customize your boroughs
surfer sofa to match your style by
selecting the color size armrests height
and leg color that's perfect for you
shipping is fast and free unlike the
rest of the furniture industry and that
we mentioned it has a built-in USB
charger this is [ __ ] ridiculous I
mean like usually used to be like guys
like Shaq would get a custom couch
because he's 9 feet tall the fact that
you get this five foot ten inch guy
could do this is incredible how did
nobody think of that before with the USB
charger enjoy 30 days of cozy cozy on
your comfortable borough risk-free or
trial borough and one of the partner
showrooms today customize your own
borough and get $75 off your order by
going to borough comm / / that's be you
are ro w calm / borough for $75 off your
purchase borough makes the luxury couch
for a real life you know we love that
Bobby Kelly he would [ __ ] love that
they should hook him up with a couch
dude it's got a USB port and it did the
armrest is right where my arm is did he
would love it then he would talk it up
and they'd sell a whole bunch of them I
was supposed to me [ __ ] sitting here
poster bola sweating like a [ __ ] guy
in the first 48
all right hims it wasn't us it was hims
66% of men lose their hair by age 35 can
I tell you guys
[ __ ] hilarious story I was at the
Laugh Factory a couple nights ago and I
get offstage and this guy comes up to me
like he does hair transplant surgery and
he's got like his card right when I just
realized the volumes way down on this
[ __ ] thing hello hello hello so the
guy [ __ ] he comes up to me after my
set he goes hey man I can fix that I
could fix that talking about my bald
head and he's got this before-and-after
photos again now here's the thing I've
told this is the third time this same
guy has approached me all right the
first time it was [ __ ] alive I
laughed it was hilarious you know
because he said the same thing he came
up to me he goes hey I can fix that I
didn't go to his place and say Amen I
don't like the way I look you know he
just walked up to me and was so
convinced that I thought I looked as
awful his he evidently thought I looked
that he thought it was totally fine to
come up to me and just say hey I can fix
that you know and I laughed and I said
no man I go I'm cool I'm cool I like the
way I look you know I'm actually getting
better roles now that I look I look like
a [ __ ] you know before I used to I
look like Howdy Doody I didn't get good
parts now you know I get to play [ __ ]
[ __ ] cuz I look like one I always
was one but I didn't always look like
one so he's like all right you know and
then I ran into him when I was down
Largo same guy and I was just like Jesus
Christ my body I'm fine I'm fine right
so anyways I was doing Kevin Nealon show
Tuesday at the Laugh Factory and I get
offstage and this [ __ ] guy comes up
to me again he goes hey you know I can
fix that and he goes I'm the best in the
business
first of all dude if you're the best in
the business then like why are you
[ __ ] running up to comics who just
got offstage at a comedy club handing
out your business card you know you're
like a [ __ ] like a rapper who just
started who's selling mixtapes out of
his [ __ ] car if you're the best in
the [ __ ] business
you know III people should be walking
into your office this is you pose you
rushing up to people right so I said
that guy I go Jesus Christ here I go
this is a third [ __ ] time he came up
to me I'm fine the way I look I look
fine he goes you look like an Aryan it's
what he said
so I finally I just kind of snapped a
little bit on him you know what I mean
because it was like it kind of was not
funny anymore where it's just like dude
like you're [ __ ] harassing me here I
don't want I'm sorry I don't want
[ __ ] hair plugs what do you do you
know what it is he wants to [ __ ] he
watched he wants a [ __ ] comedian
that's got some TV credits that he can
do it so he can be like you know you
know just just ask bill burr and I'll
stand there going I love my hair plugs
you know and his [ __ ] commercial so
he can go and get a boat because that's
what I felt like he was trying to use me
you know what I mean trying to use my
bald head so we could go out and get the
[ __ ] boat in the big tinted [ __ ] off
off of my [ __ ] you know male pattern
baldness
I thought he was gonna use me like like
[ __ ] Sharon Osbourne did to those
people on that [ __ ] album so I was
finally yeah do I go I go enough buddy
enough with you stupid [ __ ] hair
plugs I don't I don't want you dumbass
hair plugs and he's like alright sorry I
I appreciate what you do
and I felt bad because he kind of walked
away but uh how funny is that
he's [ __ ] slinking up to you in a
comedy club he does hair transplants
it's like 10 o'clock at night and he's
slinking up to me handed my business his
business card and he had the [ __ ]
nerve to say I'm the best in the
business then why does this feel so
dirty sir that he's gonna [ __ ] ask me
if I wanted an abortion
alright hims
wasn't us it was hims 66% of men lose
their hair by the age of 35 is that
right
man there's a lot of people out there
with hair plugs because you don't see
six others almost seven
guys thing is when you start to loot to
notice hair loss it's too late it's
easier to keep the hair you have that
are to replace the hair you've lost I
ask you why do guys turn to weird
solutions or do nothing when they can
turn to medicine in science well cuz you
just [ __ ] man up and accept your fate
I don't know for hims calm a one-stop
shop for hair loss skin care sexual
wellness for men
thanks to science baldness can be
optional this is true hims connects you
with real doctors and medical grade
solution to treat hair loss no waiting
room no awkward doctor visits that lease
it there's always a balding people in
the waiting room save hours by going to
for hims com hims answer a few quick
questions doctors will review and Ken's
prescribe you product products are
shipped directly to your door my
listeners get a trial month of hims for
just five dollars today right now while
the supplies last see websites for full
details this would cost hundreds if you
went to the doctors or a pharmacy go to
for hims calm / / that's for hips fo r
hims calm / / for hims calm / / ya for
those of you who don't want to be bald
personally I don't give a [ __ ] I
actually love having a shaved head
I'm not even gonna lie to you and I know
I look like a freak but it's kind of
[ __ ] awesome you know people think
you know jiu-jitsu you don't know
jiu-jitsu right
hey I can help you with that Jesus
Christ buddy I don't look bad I didn't
know I looked that bad that you could
just [ __ ] walk right I could imagine
if he gave boob jobs and he just walked
up to some check and can I help you with
that
now you look terrible what tits going
this way the other girl in the only way
all right quit the truth is most of us
are brushing our teeth wrong
good will you do it how do you brush
your teeth wrong
not for long enough and forget to change
our brush on time all right fair enough
that's because most brands focus on
selling flashy gimmicks rather than
better brushing but not quit so what
makes quip so different you might have
asked maybe you didn't ask but I asked
for you for status equip is an electric
toothbrush that's a fraction of the cost
of bulkier brushes all that's a guide
you know it was electric I have a gas
toothbrush while still packing just I
have to hook plug it into the stove or
plug it in it that would be electric
bill while still packing just the right
amount of vibration to help clean your
teeth quick built equips built-in timer
helps you clean for the dentist's
recommended two minutes with guiding
pulses that remind you to switch sides
max quips subscription plans are for
your health not just convenience they
deliver new brush heads on a dentist
recommended schedule every three months
for just five dollars including free
shipping worldwide equip also comes with
a mount that suctions right to your
mirror and unsticks to use as a cover
for hygienic travel wherever you take
your teeth and finally everyone loves
quip they were on Oprah's o list
Jesus how full of herself is she this is
the O list Oprah's olace like she
literally named it after herself twice
named one of Times best inventions and
is the first subscription electric
toothbrush accepted by the American
Dental Association plus they're backed
by a network of over 20,000 dentists and
hygienists and hundreds of thousands of
happy brushes used quip every day quip
starts just 25 bucks and if you go to
get quip qu IP com / burrow
right now you'll get your first refill
pack for free with a quip electric
toothbrush that's your first refill pack
for free at get quick calm / / spelled
GE t qu IP Cobb / /
all right the [ __ ] was I just gonna go
look up that maybe want to look
something up it wasn't for hims I have
no idea I've already forget I already
forget all right guys I apologize how
[ __ ] sick I am here just enjoy the
music and listen to a half-hour of a
Thursday afternoon podcast where I
wasn't [ __ ] sick
hopefully all right god bless you god
bless the United States of America
Republicans Democrats libertarians
people in hate groups people who love
groups antisocial people Paul people
people at the back of comedy clubs who
had enough business cards for hair plugs
all right have a great weekend you cuts
and I'll talk to you Monday
[Music]
[Applause]
did you enjoy the fourth of July you
know first of all before right out of
the gate right out of the gate I want to
thank everybody that did some dumb [ __ ]
with fireworks and had the presence of
mind to [ __ ] make a YouTube video out
of it you know so guys like make it just
sit there I was laughing my ass off last
night I went to bed nose watching people
shooting bottle rockets out of their ass
having roman candle fights seeing
somebody take one to the face do you
know some guy in Maine lit something off
on top of his [ __ ] head and he died
instantly they were like he lit off they
said some mortar something [ __ ]
insane look what kind of you know what
kind of a [ __ ] [ __ ] would do
something like that you must have had it
there's no way
everybody knows once you get up to
anything like a pack of firecrackers on
your head you like that's that's funny
you're gonna [ __ ] kill your eardrums
and you know but you're gonna survive
but what would he put an m-80 in his
mouth or something well I don't know
Bill you [ __ ] brought it up all right
relax let's just look up main guy dies
fireworks all right man shoots off
firework from top of his head dies
instantly a 22 year old man was drinking
and celebrating the 4th of July
happy birthday to America don't put it
on my head
happy birthday to America happy birthday
Michael that's how I went down 22 year
old man who was drinking and celebrating
the fourth of July tried to launch a
firework from top of his head killing
him instantly authorities said
authorities said you got to be an
authority to say that somebody's [ __ ]
dead after they light something off on
their head wait a minute wait a minute
clear clear the way yes yes he is dead
well we kind of knew that
brains all over the sidewalk watch your
mouth woman watch your mouth woman it's
one of my favorite quotes in sports over
the last [ __ ] I don't know how many
months six months
watch your mouth woman when that woman
called asla branagh it was like to be a
punk-ass [ __ ] and then that guy's going
watch your mouth woman watch your mouth
woman and you know you would think that
the broads would have had such would you
have [ __ ] difficulty with it like you
know I realized that she said something
derogatory towards him but that's no
excuse
go change your bra lady all right I love
that they didn't say anything cuz even
they knew even they knew that guy you
know that [ __ ] was out of line just
[Applause]
talking [ __ ] today they won't say what
kind of firework it was alright
apparently he thought that was a great
idea that just when you died in a stupid
[ __ ] way when somebody starts it off
when they start you eulogy off with
apparently yeah apparently this guy
thought sticking his head in the garbage
disposal was you know gonna give him a
good buzz I mean I'm sorry to bring it
up Claire but you know how did he even
get it in there oh his friends said they
thought they thought they dissuaded him
from doing it the next thing they knew
he ignited the firework and he was
killed instantly
what the [ __ ] did he shoot off there was
no rushing him to the hospital there was
no Devon left when I got there said 25
year-old Cody Jesus Christ the names of
this generation huh Devon Cody Jeep
Wrangler Devon was the kind of person
who would do something stupid absolutely
he was the kind of person who would
pretend to do something stupid to make
people laugh well he wasn't faking it
alright it's the first fireworks
fatality since they legalized fireworks
January 1st 2012 well he just [ __ ] it
up for the whole state it's bad enough
everyone's on heroin
now you're gonna give them fireworks
honey what next does Isis get their own
juice store come on people over 80% of
bottle rockets are shot out people's
anuses in this state alone this needs to
stop that's going on in Main Street
right now in Maine hi do you know me of
course you don't
I'm your regular housewife here in Maine
my son is on heroin my other son shot a
roman candle up his ass I'm sorry to be
graphic he was trying to shoot it out of
his ass but apparently his excitement
well it's getting whoo I mean in order
to light the wick you got to be able to
see it so I don't know how these things
were done when we were kids we just we
with them and we ran away we hid under
our desks that's what we did Devon was a
great person and injured New Jersey a 52
year old man blew off a large piece of
his leg below the knee when he set off a
tennis ball-sized firework in Montana
Montana Montana a 32 year old man was
killed at his Billings home in a
fireworks accident involving a mortar
tube all right at least there was some
sort of mortar round I mean mortar round
I mean first of all when you start
lighting off [ __ ] we're your neighbors
start screaming and comment you know
what do you think is gonna happen
let's look up a mortar tube here
everybody I'm learning about fireworks
through the death of my fellow Americans
I spent a mote are all right firework
mortar tubes how about some images let
me see what the [ __ ] these things look
like is there some sort of all right all
I see is army guys yeah
not good you know when when the [ __ ] you
shooting off oh there we go
well there's one that looks like a
little barbershop thing what a [ __ ]
dope he shot that off his head you know
what probably happened I would guess is
that there was some sort of discharge
from the bottom end of it in the
concussive force but it seems like there
was no Devon he [ __ ] blew his head
off and Jesus what a way to start it's
such a wonderful weekend I didn't mean
this when I was talking about funny [ __ ]
I was just talking about you know people
I haven't roman candle fights come on we
all did that [ __ ] right
that's bait that is the evolution of all
weaponry all right anything that has an
explosive device anything that it's
supposed to do anything there that
[ __ ] blow [ __ ] up you just you start
or you anything that you can shoot at a
target it always starts simple let's
light it off you know let's let's point
it in that direction at the trees right
and then what then you move up to let's
torture some insects let's shoot a bird
and eventually because you know the way
human beings are that we always try to
top one another and we get bored which
is the reason why we went from walking
to the horse to the yeah I'm really in
deep right now I know I don't want the
[ __ ] talking about eventually you're
gonna move to the the ultimate prey the
human being you know something that can
think the same way you do something that
may have done better in math than you
did you know that's the challenge this
person passed algebra
I did not we're both trying to kill one
another is you know first outside inside
last going to come into play here when
we're out in the woods our opposite
angles being congruent is that going to
be the death of me or do I just have
that extra something do I want it a
little bit more am I able to
about the fifth commandment do I have
such a strong religious background that
I can hear God's voice in my head
telling me that I'm right telling me to
deliver that animal it's not even a man
anymore it's a [ __ ] animal deliver
that animal in the express lane to its
maker right do I have that that mean
it's inevitable that's personally why I
don't [ __ ] with fireworks I don't [ __ ]
with fireworks because I know that I am
scatterbrained
and I get bored easily and I have 10,000
[ __ ] hobbies and eventually lighting
it off in the driveway is not going to
be enough for me okay I have neighbors I
have neighbors that I get along with
maybe I'm bored with the fact that I get
along with them maybe I want to stop
maybe some days you just wake up and you
just want to start some [ __ ] and you
just happen to have some fireworks that
don't just blow up they go way up in the
air and you want to shoot somebody right
anyways my condolences to anybody who
knows somebody that died and now I don't
have any condolences for the people that
died cuz you're [ __ ] dead and you're
either dead or I think you're in a
better place because someone who's dumb
enough to blow themselves up on the July
4th weekend with their own goddamn
explosives I don't think ever had the
brains to really hurt another human
being knowingly I never knowingly lied
knowingly hurt another [ __ ] human
being
I mean honestly that [ __ ] stupid
obviously could go out he's gonna hurt
somebody but you know
do you really have the mental capacity
to understand you know your actions
[Music]
hey what's going on it's bill burn it's
the Monday morning podcast for July 5th
2010 one day after the birthday of this
country happy birthday to America happy
birthday to the USA happy birthday [ __ ]
every other country you know like City
Way you [ __ ] douche bags Jesus Christ
happy birthday to one of the most hated
countries on the face of the [ __ ]
planet
you know everybody's [ __ ] on us all
those [ __ ] World Cup referees you
know people tugging on our shirts
kicking us in our [ __ ] American balls
they don't see any of it no reason why
we're out of the World Cup is because of
our foreign policy that's why that's why
we were always offsides
they never work the Ghana East does
whoever the [ __ ] kicked our ass I don't
know is the World Cups still going is
the world still watching let me ask the
world the question when your team gets
knocked out do you tap out and like yeah
[ __ ] the World Cup you know and you go
back to your hut and you grind up corn
in that little guacamole Bowl do you do
that
what exactly is done do you continue
watching I mean cuz i watch NFL football
and when the New England Patriots got by
the Baltimore Ravens I continued to
watch the the playoffs playoffs
yes playoffs I continued to watch them
and so I was wonder if you guys are so
into soccer yes I am calling it soccer
because it's it's our birthday this week
so I'm not gonna [ __ ] kowtow down to
you [ __ ] and say call it
football you know just because you have
a ball and you can only kick it with
your foot you know you guys think you're
so clever oh that's real football really
you can kick it with both feet can't you
why isn't it feet ball what's the deal
um look at me with a head of [ __ ]
steam I'm hungover to feel like [ __ ] had
a bunch of [ __ ] fourth of July
barbecue you know is it ever good is it
ever good oh look at the ribs all
slathered and [ __ ] glistening and
[ __ ] fat and you get over there and
you stick your fat american face right
into it it's all over your face like
some [ __ ] two-year-old trying to eat
birthday cake you know and you run your
hand through your hair with it get that
[ __ ] grizzled moose look going that's
right then you have sex with some
underage girl and a hot tub and you have
to flee to France because in France
that's it [ __ ] acceptable America um
no actually I had some great uh some
great food yesterday I just had too much
of it I just could not stop stuffing my
fat face I was that kind of full where I
couldn't stay in one position I was like
sitting down and then after a while that
wasn't comfortable then I'd stand up for
a minute and then that wouldn't be
comfortable then I had to like lean on
the side of the person's house [ __ ]
with the foundation at that point but it
was a good time
birthday of America actually went to a
party uh that was just a little bit into
the Hollywood Hills and was looking out
over LA and it's absolutely [ __ ]
hilarious
the amount of illegal fireworks they're
shot off I don't know in every city or
in LA in particular because I've never
had like a bird's eye view and somebody
made this hilarious joke that way as we
were looking out it looked like when
America bombed the United States I
should say the United States bombed
Baghdad and then as we were watching the
fireworks going off they should have
been like a little CNN logo down on the
left hand side of our eyeballs and then
we all had a big laugh after this person
made that hilarious joke remember that
[ __ ] you know it really made me feel
like you know what the [ __ ]
wasn't that a deep thought they really
made me think what the [ __ ]
gee bill I don't think you need to
elaborate on that anymore
I think you really summed it up not just
thinking like what would I be doing you
know if if I was sitting in a city that
was getting bombed and I worked in like
a [ __ ] you know I was like I always
say a hardware store for once bill can
he come up with a different job maybe I
put shoes on the bottom of llamas feets
feets feet you know there's a llama like
is that like an Australian animal or is
that from the middle and I said the
Midwest the Middle East every once in a
while I see a llama in this [ __ ]
country and it almost causes an accident
because you're like what the [ __ ]
happened to that pony's neck now it
really made me think like I laughed and
then I felt bad like where the [ __ ] do I
get off laughing there's nothing funny
about war even if we got to go in and we
got to do the [ __ ] there's just nothing
funny about it because there's a bunch
of people on the [ __ ] ground who had
nothing to do with [ __ ] you know they
had nothing to do with that maniac and
his Tom Selleck mustache they're just
trying to [ __ ] survive and then these
people come in there to rescue them and
they end up getting [ __ ] blown up
then Here I am feeding my face like a
fat [ __ ]
you know just full of pork cornbread
some Nell away for dessert about four
beers and I'm eyeballing a slice of
pizza watching fireworks in the [ __ ]
Hollywood Hills that looks like bad
Baghdad well we all should just
projectile vomited right there in a
tribute to the end of the Roman Empire
he enough when they used to do they had
those rooms those puking rooms you just
sat there stuff in your face and then
you would [ __ ] go in there and just
puke which is another [ __ ] reason why
these [ __ ] European country alene
heed to sit down and read a history book
they always talk about how dumb we are
the exact same [ __ ] that they're making
fun of us for they've all done - three
times over every [ __ ] one of them and
I'd rattle off the stats but I don't
know him please you can tell me that
little [ __ ] [ __ ] Napoleon didn't
stuff his fat face a little [ __ ]
Danny DeVito looking douchebag huh what
happened to him he went to Waterloo
what's up with that [ __ ] Waterloo
this is like typical [ __ ] American
[ __ ] talking I know I know
the major [ __ ] players and I know the
major battle names but I have no idea
what happened he went to Waterloo which
I believe what was that in Austria was
that right down the street in
Connecticut what a [ __ ] did that happen
all I know is he went there and he got
his little [ __ ] ass kicked did he
ride a pony into battle because he was
so little that if he actually fell off a
real horse it would be falling off like
a [ __ ] skyscraper huh that little
douche rubbing his [ __ ] stomach
because he had an ulcer because he has
that little dwarf stomach that can of
they can't digest more than a couple of
strawberries and he's sitting there
trying to [ __ ] dive in and be the big
guy he won't he won't accept it won't
accept that he's he's a little guy with
little organs and a little intestinal
tract so what does he do he stuffs his
face trying to eat his [ __ ] drill
sergeant you know eating a Bronto burger
whatever they did back then next thing
you know he's got an ulcer and there's
no pepto
[ __ ] pepto you know it's the 1500s I
did that on purpose just for all you
[ __ ] snobs I know he was around in
the 1800s
wasn't he who is it - 1700s I don't know
one of those ones where were you [ __ ]
you wore too much makeup you know and
you curled up your hair like that chick
on a little house in the Prairie that I
was making a reference to Nellie Nellie
Oleson who's got a [ __ ] book coming
out doesn't she you know see now that's
how you do it as a child star when you
fall off she never got involved in drugs
you know she just kept [ __ ] living
off of her residuals granted she had the
options because evidently that series
plays all over the world you know
she writes a book you know you just keep
milking it you just write a book still
Nellie still Nellie after all these
years and you answered the same [ __ ]
questions over and over again how close
was that character to the real you if
they're a little bit of Nellie in you is
there a little bit of Nellie in all of
us you know and people wonder why those
celebrities end up snapping in those
[ __ ] interviews somebody sent me a
YouTube video this week about Mel Gibson
who's having another rough week by the
way he still no no audio tape of him
being a douche has really come about I
think that's just the the ex-girlfriend
claiming he did some [ __ ] like that
either that or he's got a [ __ ]
unbelievable [ __ ] lawyer which you
know could be either/or but what the
hell is it where the [ __ ] is a YouTube
video oh man I was on such a roll what
is my voice hurt like I did a bunch of
oh there it is like I did a bunch of
shows this weekend was it because I was
drunk yelling at people alright Mel
Gibson's he's a YouTube video look up
Mel Gibson Dean Richard calls Dean
Richards an [ __ ] and somebody asked
me my opinion on it and I I think he was
I think he was well within his [ __ ]
right to call him an [ __ ]
basically what happens is this guy goes
the passive-aggressive route where Mel
comes on to hype his movie and Dean's
like you know hey it's great to have you
here but bah bah bah you can see melt
Mel's already defensive because he's got
that anti-semite rant hanging over his
[ __ ] head so he's already [ __ ]
just you know he can see it in his face
like [ __ ] let me just get through this
[ __ ] interview without this guy
bringing the [ __ ] up so the guy he
[ __ ] he soft sells him whatever he
did passive-aggressive oh this about the
movie dad about the movie and then he
goes yeah you know it's kind of some
familiar ground I feel like I'm visiting
an old friend which is a really kunti
way of saying like yeah I've already
seen you do this movie before but he
doesn't come out and say it
Mel handles all of it with grace and
then finally knee in the end you know he
[ __ ] suckers him with the overhand
right going oh yeah so how do you think
the public's gonna receive you and in he
goes well what do you mean he goes you
know with uh you know he's some of your
troubles that you've had in the past and
Mel goes uh well you know my life's kind
of been a rollercoaster uh and the guy
just keeps going and goes what exactly
are you talking about and he just
[ __ ] he does you know when he got
drunk and blah blah blah blah and he
brings that [ __ ] up again and Mel's like
dude to spend four [ __ ] years
Yatta Yatta yeah this is my thing it's
like one of those deals where Mel Gibson
he did say it so but my thing is if
you're gonna [ __ ] trash the guy for
it just go ahead and trash him don't sit
there and act like you're the guy's
[ __ ] buddy and then out of nowhere hit
him over the head with it so he ends up
calling the guy an [ __ ] the guy is an
[ __ ]
and the other point is that Dean
Richards guy I swear to God if you
tapped his phone if you tapped that
guy's [ __ ] phone you don't think that
that he would say anything that that
would involve some sort of apology I'm
just really tired of people acting like
they don't have any sort of [ __ ]
issues whatsoever I'm not saying that
you're a straight-up [ __ ] racist
alright beginning you never caught
yourself you know you walking down the
street it's late
at night you see some of them of a
particular race and what do you think
you're thinking the worst [ __ ] you know
and then it turns out for some reason
you have to interact with them and
they're the exact opposite of what the
[ __ ] you thought you're what they were I
mean come I don't know I'm just sick of
people when somebody does something like
that everybody gets to be like holier
than thou and act like they don't think
any [ __ ] up thoughts and secondly
second second of ly second of all I
think I'm on third of all at this point
and and in see my third point I'm just
gonna switch between numbers and letters
here Mel Gibson has a lot of [ __ ]
issues right so how do you cure the guy
of these [ __ ] hateful ish issues
you [ __ ] drag him across the goddamn
coals and rub his [ __ ] face in it I
mean I really don't think that that's
gonna make a guy with [ __ ] up thoughts
really sit back and reflect
up to that dude whether he wants to sit
back and reflect but you know I don't
think like trying to think of a good
[ __ ] analogy
I got it like when I lived in Boston I
absolutely [ __ ] hated the Yankees and
I [ __ ] hated their fans and then when
I moved down in New York and I had to
interact with them you know they weren't
as bad but I still thought that they
would douchebags at the end of the day
alright that was a bad example whatever
I [ __ ] wing the podcast you know what
I'm saying at some point I think the
public has to forgive Mel Gibson
particularly anybody that he went off on
I think you should be a nice guy to him
and then he can realize wow what the
[ __ ] was I thinking he is so and so he's
part of the group X Y & Z that I went
off on I really was a drunk douchebag
but I think if you're a [ __ ] racist
[ __ ] and you think that [ __ ] I think
mace mostly maybe you'll probably remain
that way but if you're actually truly
trying to not be a racist content more
if the group that you attacked is a
[ __ ] [ __ ] to you not a [ __ ]
[ __ ] that's a bad but like just
constantly is yelling at you I don't I
don't see where you think that that guy
is going to turn the [ __ ] corner
you know
with a [ __ ] you calling us douchebags
you [ __ ] [ __ ] oh yeah what was I
thinking you know what I mean does that
make any sense whatsoever I don't
[ __ ] know whatever look at I can
separate the racist guy from his movies
I was kidding no it's hard to it's it's
it's a [ __ ] difficult thing you know
and the guy did say it so I guess he
does deserve that but you know I just
thought that was a really [ __ ] [ __ ]
ass way I just thought if you watch the
interview the guys being really
passive-aggressive he's taking swipes at
the movie you know saying it's like oh
this is he's basically saying Mel this
is you doing [ __ ] I saw you do 20 years
ago what's up with that but he but he
was saying in this you know you know I
just felt like I was visiting an old
friend you know what about doing the
stunts is it harder to do the stunts now
that you're older you know that type of
[ __ ] yeah Dean yeah it is harder is it
harder for you to see your dick when you
sit down when you take a [ __ ] you're old
fat [ __ ]
yeah we're getting older what is your
point I'm trying to sell a movie here
you taking me out at the knees why if
you were just gonna take me out at the
knees why didn't you just do a rant on
your show rather than have me get up at
[ __ ] 5:00 in the goddamn morning for
you to pretend like you actually respect
me on some level I don't know I guess
that's my problem with the video like I
those you listen to my podcasts you know
how much I hate passive aggressiveness
it's just it's really a it's one of the
bitchiest qualities you can have as a
[ __ ] human being you know if you're
gonna be a [ __ ] standing flat-footed
with your shoulders squared up and just
hit him a hundred falls gonna say full
force just like [ __ ] Jeff farmer who
I'll be getting to later full force with
being a [ __ ] towards him you know yes
you ever piss somebody off you cut them
off in traffic and they're behind you
and you look in their face and you know
they're mad at you right and you drive
for like two two-and-a-half miles and
then you make a right and they're still
going straight and as you make a right
they drive by and then they beep at you
you know plant as they go by
back that type of [ __ ] lien on the
[ __ ] horn the second I do something
alright don't wait til I make a right
turn you could [ __ ] beep at me and
then drive away Jesus Christ that was
enough well you know what that was a
nice goddamn example that was really a
nice example um anyways I went out and I
bought some new clothes this weekend
everybody it's it's kind of one of those
weird things when you become an adult
where as a kid I don't know about you
guys I know these kids nowadays they're
all [ __ ] spoiled with their iPads you
know in a box of condoms or whatever the
[ __ ] they get at school every goddamn
day it's just picturing people like 18
listen to this throwing their hands up
like what dude we don't get that yeah
there's that weird thing when I was a
kid you got you got new clothes once a
year
you know Christmas didn't count because
those were from your grandmother and
that was please beat the [ __ ] out of me
close I guess you got a couple of things
but like basically you got new clothes
at the beginning of every year that's
how I worked in my family beginning of
every year you went down to the [ __ ]
Levi's store you got like three
different pairs of [ __ ] corduroys and
you got a new pair of sneakers and you
got like three shirts and that was it
see you next September they have [ __ ] oh
that was it that was it and the rest was
hand-me-downs from your older brothers
and sisters not sisters older brothers
or whatever our older sisters if you're
a broad you know trying to [ __ ] make
this this podcast for everybody
why don't I just sound like [ __ ] Dana
Carver's Carvey's George Bush that
sounded like that to me trying to do the
podcast for everybody not got it dad
wouldn't be prudent
that's a terrible impression bill once
you shut the [ __ ] up and talk about your
stupid clothes fine I will
my podcast I'll [ __ ] talk about
whatever I want to talk about we think
about that yes he got then that was it
for the whole [ __ ] year and your
sneakers look good till about September
30th and then and then that was it then
that was [ __ ] it but uh but the weird
thing as an adult is uh you know you
think I'm gonna say that you buy clothes
more often the reality is you don't you
don't you let a couple of school years
go by and then one day you know you have
to go to event that you haven't gone to
in a while like say like a barbecue I
can't remember the last time I went to a
[ __ ] barbecue and you start fishing
out your barbecue clothes from the
bottom of your goddamn dresser drawer
you know bring a bathing suit
I pull out this [ __ ] bathing suit
it's got a Mustang Mustang I can't even
talk this week it has a mustard stain
from like [ __ ] back when Clinton was
in office and I don't know what it was
not like I'm up on bathing suit styles
but I could just tell it was not in
style anymore and everything was just
[ __ ]
linty and old-looking and all that [ __ ]
so I was like I got damnit I got to go
to the [ __ ] mall so I go to the mall
I had to buy some new sneakers and I go
into the Foot Locker and they're selling
Lakers t-shirts that says 16 it says Los
Angeles Lakers 16 [ __ ] NBA
championships on it and the footlocker
guy comes up dressed like a ref you know
and he comes up to me and he's just like
hey sir is there anything I can help you
with I said yeah you can fix that
t-shirt right there and have it say Los
Angeles Lakers 11 NBA championships and
he's like what are you talking about I'm
like cuz you won your first five is the
Minneapolis Lakers all right six Los
Angeles Lakers it should say Minneapolis
/ Los Angeles Lakers you got that Los
Angelenos those first five championships
are not yours so why don't you [ __ ]
cave in your chest a little bit down to
about 11 championships and I'll keep
mine way the [ __ ] out there with my
seventeen NBA championships from the
Boston Celtics all of them in Boston are
you guys still confused about that LA
think about how many times have you
burned down your city you haven't burned
down
16 times you burned it down 11 times you
[ __ ] [ __ ] classic people from Los
Angeles just patting their [ __ ]
resume
you're a [ __ ] PA on a project all of
a sudden you're an executive producer
you win 11 championships as the Los
Angeles Lakers and all of a sudden now
you're walking around with 16 NBA
championships you got a lot of [ __ ]
nerve just like Tiger Woods wife you got
a lot of [ __ ] nerve stand the [ __ ]
down I don't I can't even if I talked
about this last week on the podcast but
after watching some World Cup soccer and
watching these [ __ ] pansies every
time anybody comes near I'm flopping
around like they just got [ __ ]
tasered
I was like you know what I bet Pau Gasol
that's where he learned his flopping
around on the [ __ ] court out there
either that or used to watch a fishing
show I can't figure out what he just
outgrew the sport the big [ __ ] goof uh
his [ __ ] face
how do you [ __ ] start squinting but
before you even start driving to the
goddamn rim
if Pau Gasol ever puts out a ringtone
that's what it's gonna sound like he
followed me oh I just can't get over it
I just can't get over that we [ __ ]
lost to those [ __ ] and Kobe choked
and POW choked they both choked in Game
seven and no one's ever gonna [ __ ]
remember if it wasn't for this podcast
I'm gonna be bringing it up for years
alright anyway so it's July everybody
we're over the hump another year another
year is flying by alright and I want you
guys to realize that it is July 5th
alright and the end of August is coming
so you make sure that you do something
fun every goddamn weekend all right I
don't know about you guys as you get
older I don't know what the [ __ ] happens
it's May and you like oh my god summers
coming and then the next thing you know
yeah it's it's the it's it's over and
you're like I didn't do [ __ ] I didn't do
one [ __ ] fun thing all I did was work
and write is you getting mad and you're
gonna actually examined
how the [ __ ] you let another summer slip
away all of a sudden its preseason
football and you get so [ __ ] excited
that you forget that you wasted another
summer yeah it's you guys a question
when's the last time you went in or
tubing down a goddamn River isn't that
what you're supposed to do in some sort
of Wrangler Jean cut-offs oh by the way
by the [ __ ] way speaking of Wrangler
do you want to know why that that that
reference was in my [ __ ] head when I
went I'm really bringing the voice down
for this story everybody when I went to
go shopping yesterday you know which is
one of the great activities you can do
with your girlfriend when you need new
clothes I mean if you ever just want to
watch your girls face just light up just
say that to her
hey sweetheart you want to go shopping
oh my god so we go over to the [ __ ]
mall and I'm like alright I need to buy
some clothes some barbecue clothes some
clothes that I can wear hanging out a
barbecue so I won't get trashed at this
[ __ ] barbecue cuz it's gonna be a
bunch of comedians there I'd already get
a bunch of [ __ ] if there was a bunch of
pipe fitters down there or whatever they
would already be breaking balls so I got
to go down there I got to be looking
alright so we go to the mall and she
takes me into Target or is the women
call it tarjay that's the little [ __ ]
oh my God we're being frisky joke and
this is the amazing thing about women is
women can go into a Target and find
something and and make it work as they
say god I can't believe I know that
[ __ ] expression okay I'm really gonna
have to bring up my excuse here my girl
watches that fashion show and I actually
am aware of that guy with the glasses
who goes make it work and this is
basically how it works my girl watches
those reality shows and I might even
bring her in here hey Nia you want to
come in on the podcast
all right all right Nia's coming in on
the podcast everybody I'm gonna explain
basically how it works when I the lovely
Nia everybody I was actually I was
talking about how when I needed some new
barbecue clothes right that you took me
to Target and I was beginning to say
that Target like there's something about
women that you can go into a target and
actually whatever you find you can make
it work and then I realized that that
was the saying of that yes so now I'm
feeling like yeah like people can be
like you actually watch those shows how
long do I last when I watch those
reality shows with you about five
minutes before I kick you out kick you
kick me out why because you dick
what do you mean I don't have like a
dick I start I start thrashing the
people on the show yeah well you make
little jokes and stuff and it's funny
and then you get annoying and you hinder
my ability to enjoy it so I kick you out
all right
I wanted offend my thing so she brings
me into target I thought to go what's
that I thought we were going in there
for you to find workout clothes yeah
workout clothes which so she brings me
in into the corner of the store and she
shows me these [ __ ] I didn't even
know champion still made workout clothes
and they've since changed their logo and
she's like huh look at these you like
these workout clothes and it literally
look like the kind of [ __ ] you'd wear
like you know when you get you get
arrested for something and then seven
years later when they let you out of
jail they give you your clothes back
that's what the [ __ ] look like yeah
and I said yeah and they're also like
that Jordan level where it's all the way
down to your calves still if they don't
realize that it's actually they found a
happy medium between the Larry Bird's
and the Michael Jordan yeah which is a
little bit above the knee and so what
did I do I went in there and I said I'm
I was in there for like three seconds
I'm like yeah I'm not buying any shitty
really Eretz and you got [ __ ] mad at
me because
bill whenever we go shopping together
and I have suggestions or whatever you
just walk in look for not even three
seconds or being very generous to
yourself you walk in your ad enough I
can doing this you don't even look you
don't even take the time I was right but
I was right
Mia they had tank tops next to like
Dickies side like yeah like what are we
gonna make out a [ __ ] toilet and then
go play some hoop it's not it's not for
men target is not for men I don't think
it is that buy in can openers and beer
glasses that's what the [ __ ] they're
getting then I bought what are they
gonna buy slacks they have lots of
t-shirts and stuff that you could have
gotten you know oh yeah I could have got
some sneakers in there too with the
velcro [ __ ] snap things over the
front is it to say you know they lost
part of my foot in a boating accident I
don't know I don't believe in that
unless you're a [ __ ] tennis player if
I were a tennis player I would want cute
tennis outfits but if it's just me in
here doing my stupid Jillian Michaels
workout I don't know how did [ __ ] did me
going into getting some [ __ ] for going
to a barbecue slash some new workout
clothes go to me wanting to buy a cute
tennis outfit I brought you in here to
try to save face because I said make it
work and now you just I'm just
further into the muck boy all right
that's it people I had to go to a
barbecue and I went to the mall and I
bought a cute outfit yes I did I look
respectable although I I did the classic
old guy thing where I had the brand new
sneakers and the older socks for half a
second I wanted to suggest that you wear
socks that were a little bit lower so
that you wouldn't see so much of the
sock they were ankle level I know but
you could have got them like a little
bit lower so I don't know oh and have
that little ball in the back of a
when did those become guy socks it was
Chris Everett Lloyd's I gotta be honest
with you and ask I don't know have
people write in about this I feel like
when you wear shorts sneakers and socks
if there's too much socks showing it
gets a little dorky yeah you know this
is classy you so you basically I'm the
guy you love and you let me walk around
this barbecue yesterday looking like a
douche it's your own way to keep the
woman's away from me that way you didn't
look like a douche she looked really
good and be anytime well I don't know if
we should get into this but why why not
what are we gonna have an argument on
here do you think these people gave a
[ __ ] about us we're trying to fill up
they do an hour of their day I think
they're at work right now you know mad
they are that they have to work July
fifth and the company across the street
has a cool boss and they're actually
closed what is the problem
[Music]
well I remember making a suggestion
yesterday and that didn't work out too
good either
oh you don't talk about that no you
don't want to talk about the fact that I
said your dress was a little linty Dell
your dress was a little linty yes and we
came and then and then what I kind of
done yeah and this is this is the
hardest like help guys out here yeah but
you know what the hardest [ __ ] thing
is when is when standing up now I'm
standing up now because I want to make a
point here is it had nothing to do with
you I was just I was you know I was like
you know the dress you just dress I've
been worn just a little bit too low it's
just one of those ones you throw over
look at me I'm already getting nervous
trying to explain to you I said I'll buy
you another one and then the next thing
you know it was just like it's [ __ ]
there was there was the meltdown and all
that and I use the meltdown mom started
crying in the mall on the birthday of
our country Wow
I don't sorry everyone Wow I'm African
American there's still a little
annoyance there so I'm not exactly yeah
America's freedom [ __ ] you had to take
it all the way to there anyway wait a
minute this isn't about that oh my god
do you realize that what else we're
gonna they're gonna get well why don't
you go the [ __ ] back to [ __ ] Africa
they should say go ahead let them get it
all out there I know there you go Mel
Gibson spit it all out there Jesus
Christ yeah you know I try to keep it
light and you just went Fox News on me
you just went Fox News on me or whatever
no actually no the ultra liberal played
on some sort of website me Renee hates
this country that's not what I'm saying
what are you saying I'm just saying that
you know
wait a second when people celebrate
fourth of July are they really like
eating their barbecue and drinking their
beer thinking about this country and our
forefathers and wouldn't really know
they're not they're just like I don't
have work tomorrow and I get to get
drunk yeah most of them are telling
people happy fourth of July like it's
Christmas
no one cares I don't think your
popularity Mia was through the roof on
this podcast and now you know what's
funny was our listeners on a journey
know what a rollercoaster that's what
that's exactly what Mel Gibson just said
I just watched that thing and he just
said that he just said that [ __ ] know
what that word that this does [ __ ]
know passive-aggressive douchebag was
sitting there going what was came on
acting like he wanted to talk about his
movie but he really just wanted to sort
of steer it back around to that time he
what he went off so and then he was he
was going like he goes well you know
when I saw your movie I just felt like I
was visiting an old friend that we were
on some some familiar ground he was
basically saying like yeah I've seen
this [ __ ] movie before but but he was
doing it in this singsong he [ __ ]
voice
so yeah so he starts with that then he
asked then he asked about doing stunts
is it harder to do now that you're an
old [ __ ] was basically the subtext and
then in the end he goes how do you think
America is gonna receive you so then Mel
had to play it off like he didn't know
what he was talking about and then he
basically brings it around and then the
end Mel calls him an [ __ ] and at one
point when Mel was sitting goes well you
know my life has been sort of a roller
coaster he did say that Sonia do you
want to try too so you do you think Mel
Gibson all right well look I'm not gonna
lie to you you guys did have a rough
couple hundred years there at the
beginning of this country started off a
little slow for you guys maybe 400 it
was a couple hundred it was not it was
go online right now yeah this [ __ ]
country is only 230 [ __ ] four years
old yeah 1776 that's when he officially
became America 400 Mia it's the two
thousands right so that would be in the
1600s you guys came over with those
[ __ ] pilgrims and their butter what
do they make oh they're oil what what we
use the pilgrim as it was one of this
old call any gas nobody remembers those
guys showing my age I don't know they
came over with smallpox infected
blankets to the Indians that's all I
know who did the pilgrims on the Nina
the Pinta the Santa Maria no no no no no
we didn't do the smallpox think like way
way way way you're getting ahead of
yourself we came over and we starved to
death and then we acted like we were
friends with the Indians going hey man
like how do you make what I will kill
you why don't you teach us how right how
to make yes and then once they did that
we were just like would it be awesome if
we all lived here and they didn't hey
Jemma died why don't you sneeze into
this [ __ ] blankets and we'll give it
to him yeah we went germ warfare way
back in the day yeah and then we gave
them like 48 dollars for the entire
Midwest Louisiana Purchase no we didn't
we buy that off of France yeah yeah but
that off of France but whatever so
the French were over here murdering the
Indians birthday I don't [ __ ] know
all I know we say cut yeah so this
podcast is proving that we both yeah we
don't know [ __ ] I don't know [ __ ]
watching people judging us right now
well it's one of those things like you
know like that type of [ __ ] you learn
and it just really doesn't come up in
your everyday life you know as I figure
out how to get these bankers off my
goddamn back the Louisiana Purchase
really doesn't come up I guess can you
name can you listen let's see how dumb
we are can name as many American wars as
you possibly can bang don't with the
easy ones right off the back the Cold
War Wow Wow my girlfriend's an idiot all
right I admit it I might I don't know
anything about it so then what are you
trash in the country for I don't know
can you just tap out and just say you're
sorry just say you're sorry just say
because what are you doing ah do you
think it's any better anywhere else do
you when you really look around the
world where is it where is everybody
really holding hands and all getting
along
isn't it everywhere that is they have
and they have
okay let's talk about Sweden let's not
let's talk about how you all day all the
universal health care they only let
good-looking people in Stockholm Sweden
and the second we got out of there we
took the train out of there all of a
sudden that's where they kept all the
brunettes all those Muslim looking dudes
and that shitty [ __ ] gray communist
look in mall we went to you remember
that [ __ ] Manhattan example but maybe
and more you know but you know
international richer cities you have
people who yes can afford to get their
hair done once a week and have gym
memberships and nice clothes and eat it
yes just like there yeah just like here
I know but I was just saying
it's the same thing same thing you don't
think those Blondie's look down on the
brunettes and then the brunettes go we
out with him where the [ __ ] were they I
mean we were both walking down the
street in Stockholm going Jesus Christ
everyone's beautiful yeah look at that
guy yeah I felt like a [ __ ] mongrel
there was hot guys workin at H&M like
model guys yeah like like like movie
star looking chicks working at like a
newspaper stand yeah yeah and then we'll
remember that we got outside this thing
I'm telling you everywhere you go you go
over to England they got their
Rothschilds they got their Royal [ __ ]
family yeah you know they won't even
mingle with those [ __ ] people who
work on the tube or whatever the [ __ ]
they do right and then people in London
they look down on people in Liverpool
and people in Liverpool look down on
people in another city but I only know
two cities in England right right yeah
so there you go it's all the same [ __ ]
what do you think I'm gonna go you're
gonna you're gonna move to where you're
gonna go to Canada and they're gonna be
nicer apparently they're very nice in
Canada really
really you think so I don't know he just
threw Toronto out there I've never been
there so you know this was supposed to
be a nice cute segment I didn't think
that it was really it oh you and your
clothes what going to target next thing
you know you see yeah next thing you
know you were you were having a reality
moment hissy fit I am so not celebrating
the birthday of this country okay I am I
am so mad at America right now took you
20 minutes to come back around it is I
do like living here I don't have a
problem not just like this booking could
be sucks man I'm not like man let me
tell you something near that's how we
talk whenever we talk about hippie
really liberal people we always we
always end our sentences with me and
yeah my a n o if you guys want to see
the ultimate hippie here's here's a good
rainbow yeah YouTube video of the week
look up
sent you Sena me yosemite yosemite
yosemite mountain giant double rainbow
this guy you have to watch this video
yeah this guy if he's on drugs he's the
coolest guy ever but if he's sober he's
one of the biggest he's such a douche he
had to live in the wilderness he
basically sees a full-on double rainbow
yeah what does it mean and he starts
[ __ ] cry I don't want to read it I
don't ruin it for you
here's another one I have that like this
is an unbelievable week for YouTube
videos here jones's good ass BBQ and
foot massage look that one up Joneses
good ass BBQ and foot massage you got to
see that and this is one of the
creepiest videos I've ever seen creepy
weird hippie yoga teacher / farmer yeah
you got a look at that one and
terrifying and then possibly my favorite
I've ever seen if you guys are wrestling
fans you guys know how I love Ric Flair
and when he got on the mic and started
talking about who he was gonna fight
that weekend there was nobody better you
got to see this look up best wrestling
promo ever jump and Jeff farmer this guy
is the worst
I have ever seen and he's so in that
this like for videos like like the Mean
Gene guy is going jumping Jeff last week
that you know the one they actually do
the DVD boys jumping Jeff last week you
got attacked by so-and-so you know how
do you you know and he really he really
beat you down and then you're supposed
to jump in well let me tell you
something coming this Saturday at the
Royal Rumble but he doesn't he just goes
you know and he really beat you down and
the guy just goes yep and then there's
this long awkward pause well he turned
the tables on me in a way that I didn't
appreciate you just got to see it
there's like four of them and then
there's another person who actually
where does this one fat nerd Wow
gangster threatens ex not at all one
that's all one get and then it says Gil
DS whatever that is
GUI L di es I know if they spelt it
wrong or if that's a video game it's
basically it's some really fat woman who
got kicked off playing video games and
she's really pissed off about it and she
starts showing some of the moves she
learned in jiu-jitsu block strike it's
really bad just just check all of those
out but uh it's almost getting the point
where I have to wrap up the podcast so
Nia you [ __ ] pinko commie thanks for
coming on the podcast and spewing your
[ __ ] hatred hatred I'm not a common
you got the love/hate thing which I'll
never I'll never be able to appreciate
as a white guy because my life is it's
awesome and this kind of so perfect
anything it's tremendous I get a USA
Today in a bag of cash every day from
the government yep you're a white male
ages 18 to 45 oh it's perfect bankers
don't [ __ ] me over it's tremendous no
you love living in this country you love
the fact you can you know make something
out of yourself you can really come from
nothing and that's the thing you know
you're really trying to save it right
now don't speak a word and then they
give somehow rise up amongst the ranks
and have a great like Cesar Millan the
dog whisperer yeah look at him look at
him yeah see he did it he came into this
country illegally right then he swim
across the river with like 12 dogs tied
to his back isn't that how he came in so
he's become yeah so there you go Tyler
Perry jumping Jeff farmer Billy Carter
well yeah Oh immigrants all right that
[ __ ] english-speaking lady on So You
Think You Can Dance Arnold
Schwarzenegger Arnold Schwarzenegger
yeah look at him californ young in
California
he's pretty impressive yeah you love
this country but there are some things I
bother me about it like everyone else
everyone else has various issues with
this country too maybe I'm not supposed
to talk about it cuz it's the fourth of
July now you know you're not it's one of
those things I I know what you say look
you guys you know thank you you know you
go down to the corner store next to no
twelve cops are pulling you out of your
car you know beating the crap out of you
I get it yeah that doesn't happen to me
I get annoyed this how spoiled I am as a
white guy I get annoyed at airport
security when they wanna they want me to
go through the little misty thing are
you a terrorist
I get so [ __ ] mad and I remember in
that moment going like why I can't
imagine how those Mexican dudes in
Arizona are feeling right now getting
pulled over every five seconds yet I'm
sure they're not excited about fourth
yeah well what do you what are you
supposed to do what are you supposed to
do you know spatial profile I don't know
you know what I think
Pat once the Sun Goes Down and you're
outside everybody racially profile see
you do you have to think the worst of
people so you can get to your car in the
parking lot okay yeah if I see a black
dude or Latino dude they're in a gang if
I see a white guy he's a serial killer
or a pedophile you know okay
yeah if I see a woman she's a [ __ ]
she's a streetwalker we're not
interested lady children if I see
children their children of the corn yeah
they just they just came out of the
milkweeds yeah you have you have to
racially profile and at night whatever
and I think the bigger [ __ ] you are
slash the more vulnerable you are like
someone like me never took any martial
arts training I just you know I got like
about 705 all within my which is with my
brothers you know so those don't count
they have to stop at a certain point
because they have to answer to your dad
but like I I go out in the parking lot
you know fiber fought off in the world
not as much as you I'm gonna that's the
point was gonna make like a woman feels
more vulnerable right yeah like I don't
walk around worried about getting raped
the only time I have to worry about that
is if I go to prison you know yeah knock
on wood so what at what time do you
start racially profiling when the Sun
Goes Down so during the winter during
the winter it starts earlier like around
five five no you know what it is this is
when when the second shift comes in if
you know what I mean
when the second shift comes in that's
when I start racially profiling the
beginning the day people get up at 8:00
in the morning where no matter what
color you are you get up at 8:00 in the
morning you're a good person all right
you work to the end of the day generally
speaking you're a good person unless
you're that serial killer who just goes
to work every day and like yeah but I'm
just saying generally speaking or got a
[ __ ] piece of [ __ ] on Wall Street or
a banker look it there's a lot of flaws
in my theory all right but I'm talking
about I'm talking about just like
worrying about physical violence okay if
you get up eight in the morning like
it's very hard to get your ass kicked
between 8:00 and 5:00 in the morning and
5:00 in the afternoon that's what I'm
saying
but so but after once the Sun starts
going down and the second shift comes
out you know that's when like that
that's when you know all of a sudden the
[ __ ] 28 days people come up from the
manholes you know drug dealers come out
the fiends come out depending on where
you're at that's when yes that's right
that's right the [ __ ] stalkers the
guys with the date rape drug who
honestly puts the date rape drug in
somebody's morning coffee you know do it
what was the last time somebody got
raped when the Sun was up the Sun was up
I know if you get raped
the Sun is up you're asking for it oh my
god do I have to top your I don't like
this country thing I'm trying to bring
some of the hate onto me okay good
yes so that you uh yeah I really profile
at night but if there's a bigger group
of people around and I feel safer than
the racial
racial profile profiling goes down but
seriously if I if I you know if you're a
white guy with the shaved head during
the day you have cancer at night you're
part of you're part of a [ __ ] Aryan
group yeah I think I would be nervous if
I was coming out of somewhere or and
there was a whole gang of white guys
that were like look like they were in a
frat and they were being loud and rowdy
that would make me really nervous
if I was a witch and rape is Right rape
is right dude jagerbomb or some [ __ ]
like that you know slapping each other
on the back with their letterman jackets
yes because because you saw the accused
right I mean what are you basing this on
I don't like those I don't like Jackie
kind of frat guys anyway such a great
podcast okay yeah see that's the thing
everybody does it which gets me back to
this everybody does that [ __ ] so and
then when somebody and yeah and then
when somebody steps out of line
everybody gets to act like they don't
think anything [ __ ] up and I'm not
saying you know that I that this is
something right about like they look
there's gray areas where you have to
think the worst of people so you can get
to your [ __ ] car unlock it get in the
[ __ ] yeah I got freaked out the other
night when I got in my car I just
immediately felt like there was someone
in the back seat like one of those
horror movies and then I was also
nervous because I had been singing with
the radio it's like great this person's
gonna kill me and they think I'm a nerd
[Laughter]
especially with the bucket seats it's so
easy to reach around just stab you in
the [ __ ] chest we're back in the day
okay well I won't i won't say that there
oh by the way by the way everybody I've
made the decision yeah basing by you
guys you know to like listen we both
exposed a lot of ugly parts about
ourselves so before you guys fire off
any [ __ ] emails trashing my
girlfriend or me or whatever look in the
[ __ ] mirror
okay go go look go look at your cookies
before you delete them on the Internet
look at the last [ __ ] 17 websites you
went to so let's let me ask you that how
about that that's a great podcast
segment let me hear and I want to hear
from everybody men women black white
Latino Asian I want to hear you guys I
want to hear like some of the times when
you know you've you've done your own
little racially profiling or you looked
or people who aren't white how you think
how you look at some YP because I think
that's really interesting like you don't
hear that like it's always white people
on TV who have to like confessed and
apologize behind the podium like my old
bit going like you know they had that
rap music it was loud I got nervous I
didn't realize that they were the swim
team and they were just trying to get
amped up didn't you see them in the in
their little speedos I don't know the
music just blurred everything out you
know so I want to hear some I'm gonna
hear basically I want to hear from
[ __ ] everybody
but basically times went when you've
you've thought [ __ ] like that or
whatever I don't know just so we can get
something positive others because so
many times somebody makes a comment like
that like you made that kind of give a
[ __ ] about the country's birthday and
then immediately that's that's the
soundbite they take and then and then it
becomes all it then you actually get
into oh yeah yeah cuz your uncle gun you
know got the [ __ ] kicked out of him
because his muffler was dragging as he
drove himself to church the cops felt
that they needed backup yeah so alright
yeah ok so what's what was that I just
lost my entire train of thought you were
saying you want people to write in all
dumb but I was going on I was going on
there was one other [ __ ] thing that
happened yesterday I decided you guys
speak into the mic oh you said yeah I've
decided to was this about the car oh yes
the car the car I want to get no yeah
this is it okay my girlfriend's be on
[ __ ] cool right a little pork coming
up tails like you know you guys like
that air bubble just comes up my
girlfriend's beyond cool I'm gonna get
I'm gonna get that Dodge Challenger I'm
gonna get it and I actually I was
looking at the one down
with the [ __ ] stick shift I don't
know when I'm getting it but I'm getting
that card okay [ __ ] if I gotta get a use
one but and I think it's hilarious
because the stick shift one you actually
have to pay a gas guzzler tax thirteen
hundred bucks out here because it only
that's even better so I keep the [ __ ]
yeah passenger seat looking cute all
right Missy so anyways I think it's
funny like it says it gets 14 miles city
which means if you actually drive it
like a [ __ ] any sort of a man you're
only getting like nine [ __ ] kill my
fun all right no that's gonna be the car
will drive the Prius around like a
couple of queers right we'll do that and
then it's a car see [ __ ] that's a great
it's like a great girlfriend she's a
cheap date she doesn't want anything and
then that'll be the [ __ ] that I bring
out every Sunday the garage comes up
make the tires squeal capture the last
drop a youth I've had I know that you
know cuz I actually I looked at a bunch
of cars I looked at it like those used
BMWs I can't believe it's that someone
already farted in this car seat you know
they try to like they're brand new and I
just think everything-everything looks
like a [ __ ] Mercedes or a BMW and
that Dodge Challenger despite the fact
that the Camaros out there and the
Mustang it still is one of the most
unique looking badass cars out on the
road and I know it's American which
means it can go [ __ ] in a straight
line it's the [ __ ] but if you take a
turn unlike those yep over yeah unlike
those German cars there's a little
excitement with it you know ya know you
don't give a [ __ ] you don't you cheat my
girl doesn't want me to get the car it's
so much money
yeah no I get it again what's why yeah
that's why you cool yeah oh my god get
that and I'm gonna sit whenever you want
a new guitar I say go get it you earn
the money to spend on it so thank you
yes you're very supportive about giving
me the green light to spend my money by
myself that's a great thing you know
what this is the long she's been on the
podcast
you bring a lot to the podcast okay you
bring you bring jokes you bring a bubbly
attitude you bring a little controversy
you bring a little controversy I was
really surprised I was really surprised
but you know should I not have said that
I know you should have because there's
no way anybody shut it off after that
there's no way anybody shut it off after
that and I I think generally speaking
we'll get good emails but there will be
a bunch of [ __ ] douchey once I would
like to point out that back in the day I
really wanted to get one of those flag
bikinis I think they were so like hot
and sexy and whatever but then there you
go you really look like a trashy
especially if you wear it in a different
country if you buy one of those near I
will learn to ride a [ __ ] motorcycle
just so you could be on the back with
your booty crack peeking out I saw that
like there's no way for a woman to ride
on the back of a motorcycle without her
[ __ ] underwear hanging out I saw this
skinny girl was on the back of a bike
yesterday and her entire like you know
the thong will you have like it's not
it's not a g-string it's the thong so
you have that slice of pie bit of fabric
yeah it was where where the the [ __ ]
stamp tattoo should have been by the
time she leaned forward yeah that was
great it was America speaking of which I
saw a girl a couple well I saw her at
this this last pool party I went to and
she's a great girl but she has a
made-in-the-usa tattoo in the [ __ ]
stamp area wow it's God bless her awful
she's a great girl and I said oh so are
you you know in the armed forces or
something no but I'll [ __ ] the whole
base you put the microphone gigs I love
I love what this country stands for and
I'm really proud to be an American and I
said alright you let her get away with
that I mean what was I gonna say okay
that I respect that you know what were
you gonna say cuz I thought you know I'm
just really patriotic yeah now
you'reyou're right I just kind of
accepted it she said she I asked her she
gave me an answer
I moved on
and now exposing her on the body this
sari you were talking about how like you
know because I'm always looking at cars
right now on the internet and all that
type of [ __ ] and he was saying why do
they always have like the women draped
over them and all that because the whole
thing it's that guy visual thing mm-hmm
you know what I mean like when I when I
look at Dee I'm not glad you like when I
was looking at that challenger I
actually got I got a little aroused and
I'm not even I'm not even joking
are you kidding no I'm serious remember
how you wanted to get off the lot but I
was sort of lingering with one of my
hands at my pocket I had filled up a
little bit I know what I'm saying like
she is tapped into that with that
made-in-the-usa thing Oh like guys will
be into that that whole sort of like
[ __ ] I got a bear I got a [ __ ] car
and this is my [ __ ] woman north of
July
you got a sparkler she's blowing you
she's actually a lesbian
is she good-looking lesbian that's where
I draw the line oh there you go okay
yeah I have no tolerance for not
good-looking lesbians I'm really a snob
but a caller ate a lot of lesbian I like
oh now you just dug the hole again I
like good-looking lesbians and I like
because you're a straight man that has a
sea of being with like a couple
I'll just jerk off in the corner like a
gentleman
I would rather you met wanting to have a
threesome with lesbians and say you just
want to be a creep I want to wear a
raincoat yeah I'm in my creepy years I'm
42 dark socks pulled up to the knees
wingtip sneakers shoes I mean um no I
don't I don't have like any I don't have
any I have zero tolerance be attractive
as a lesbian step up your game I have
had it why mediocre-looking lesbians
there is one group of people in this
country that I think needs to get out
take the head off me
they're talking about these illegal
immigrants as long as you're
good-looking you can come into this
[ __ ] country I am evil yeah that's but
I get to stay for some reason okay
please what please how hard did you
laugh the other day when you you you
would put those little fashioned [ __ ]
slits in your in your jeans and I was
joking that I was gonna do it my jeans I
said what would you do if I did that to
my jeans exposing my creamy thighs how
hard did you laugh I'm a [ __ ] mutiny
I'm one step away from being a [ __ ]
albino alright we're all I get we're
like an hour two minutes in here the
very controversial Neil Rene he'll
everybody look at that took up like an
hour your day had a fourth everybody
fourth and I'm sorry if you had to work
today I hope this this podcast made it a
little more enjoyable and hey can I get
it god bless the troops or something
from you absolutely god bless the troops
100% there you go there you should go
perform for them they're doing a lot so
you
go do that gig in the front lines I'm
gonna [ __ ] do it I think you should
doing that and I'm getting the [ __ ]
challenger hey America they don't get
nearly as a pre I mean everyone says
they appreciate the troops but I don't
know that they get a lot of love
especially from people who are anti this
war but they're doing a lot of [ __ ] that
most people wouldn't do so I do mend
them which goes back to my a brave my
video said bit that I was doing when
they were saying being a mother is the
toughest job on the planet really go
fight a [ __ ] war
lady put you a bro and I go make a pie
it's America's birthday it's America's
birthday all right thanks for listening
everybody talk to you next week
[Music]
you